let's start it out pretty good so folks
this one is a patreon sponsored review
so I suppose that counts is giving my
plug for my patient on page out of here
early link down in the description hey
um so it's also somewhat timely because
the second season of altered carbon will
be out later this year I don't know
exactly when I didn't bother to check
because that's more research into this
thing than I care to do because if the
intro didn't give it away I have really
no interest in a second season of the
show why don't we start with a little
bit of sort of general plot and premise
and setup since I don't know how well
viewed this show actually is so we are
in a technological future how far into
the future we don't actually really know
I would imagine we're talking ballpark
between three and four hundred years I
say that just because people are basic
if they can afford it they effectively
live forever when we meet some
characters who are 250 some 1 years old
so it has to be far enough in the future
that the technology that was created to
even allow them to do that had to be in
place and then they lived another 250
years past that so who the heck knows
but visually it's it's well first of all
visually it's actually looks really good
this is one of the things that I will
consistently praise about the show it
looks very good the action scenes are
well done however um they only get
partial points for the fact that it
looks really good since about 80% of the
production design was just a prom Blade
Runner I mean that's that's what the
majority of the series looks like it
just looks like Blade Runner now I have
mentioned this before Blade Runner is
one of my favorite films ever so you'd
think that would predispose me to this
but in a lot of ways it kind of
it doesn't do the film that sorry film
the show any favors because it doesn't
hold up on comparison but I'll get into
that a bit later but anyway so you're
you're in a blade runner style future
but instead of having androids who look
exactly like people what we're dealing
with instead is the ability of people to
basically have a consciousness
transferred to different bodies at this
point a physical body is generally just
called somebody's sleeve now it is
basically you have this implant in the
back of your spine called the stack and
as long as that is not damaged or
destroyed a body can die the stack can
be it can be stuck into a new sleeve and
the person can just continue to live and
if you are especially wealthy you can
actually even clone a bunch of identical
body so you don't even have to get used
to a new one so that's the sort of
general premise and world that were
working with in story-wise the main
character is is a guy by the name of
Kovach now kovai played by Joel Kinnaman
I believe his first name is Takashi and
if that sounds weird that like a
character named katashi Kovich is played
by Joel Kinnaman well that's because the
body that he's in is not his original
sleeve so we actually do have a little
bit of the the live-action version of
the ghost in the shell' thing where we
have a non-white character in a white
actors body except I don't think this
actually bachas that idea the way that
ghost in the shell' does because first
of all there doesn't actually really
seem to be much in the way of racial
dynamics in this society one would
assume just because switching our bodies
is so dang easy in the first place it's
probably erased or at least blurred some
of these distinctions in the first place
and it doesn't really tackle any any of
that sort of stuff plus it doesn't play
a twist which was a big part of ghosts
in the shells mistake anyways he is he's
actually what's called an envoy or he's
actually the last one the envoys were a
resistance group who were attempting to
basically undo this system with the
stacks and people's ability to to just
Reese leave and keep living they thought
that was fundamentally wrong and a
really bad thing for Humanity but they
were defeated they were all killed and
Kovacs was the last one now he got put
on ice his stack was retained but it was
he wasn't received he then gets stuck
into this body and is basically hired as
as an outside well I say outside he's
effectively bought and paid for and
owned but as a as a personal sort of
detective for one of the wealthiest
people in the world so this guy somebody
tried to kill him and actually they more
or less succeeded like there's a this
guy's got a bajillion fail-safes even if
his stack is damaged like he has backups
that can you know he gets backed up at a
regular basis so basically his entire
mind can be reloaded from a save but you
know it was all done during a loop where
it might not have happened now he did
survive but there's a there's dead time
from when his last backup was saved
until when he got restored so there's
about an hour that he just or maybe it's
more than an hour he hasn't he's missing
a chunk of time I forget the amount of
time now so he doesn't know who tried to
kill him or why only the Hat somebody
came very close to doing it any hires
Kovach to find out who that is and of
course all this is complicated by the
fact that a fair amount of the suspect
pool are people who can really them's
reefs leave themselves into other bodies
and if they're wealthy and have the
means they can do that you know ah
we'll whenever they want and so you know
getting a video of like oh well that I
know that face it was that person that
doesn't necessarily mean something now
on paper this is all really solid that's
a really good way to complicate a
mystery story problem is the show
ultimately isn't about the mystery it
doesn't stay that way tail end of
Episode six and then in episode 7 was
where completely went off the rails but
it was headed that way for a bit like
Episode four I actually while watching
it I said this out loud I'm like oh so
help me God if they do this specific
thing that I feel like they might do I'm
gonna be really ticked off and then next
episode which was episode five they did
it and basically if I hadn't been
commissioned and I wasn't being paid to
watch it watch it
episode five is the point I would have
bailed I said I'm not I'm not watching
this anymore and it just got dumber
it got dumber and stupider episode seven
is absolutely where the entire thing
just breaks because episode seven is the
big flashback episode to Kovach's
history and not only does it tell us
almost nothing we couldn't have already
guessed that it's also really horribly
written and acted the writing is
actually it was kind of wavering even up
to that point there's a police detective
by the name of ortega who's like
especially like her line readings are so
just look that the dialogue is so on the
nose and so inelegant that there's a
fair chunk of the actors don't really
seem to know how to deliver it and she
was one of them so I was already
questioning the writing but episode 7 oh
man the show doesn't know what subtext
is it doesn't know how to have
characters have a conversation about
something but in reality they're really
talking about something else
no they just talk about this thing they
just talk did they just monologue the
themes to each other and this pseudo
poetic pretentious crap and here's the
thing funny thing was about Episode
seven it actually made me appreciate
Joel Kinnaman a little bit more because
first of all I told Kim has never really
done much for me I haven't seen him in a
lot but he's never really done much for
me and he wasn't doing much for me in
this I find him wooden I find him
unengaging I don't find it particularly
charismatic or you know just he's not
someone that my eye is drawn to it just
isn't but when we had the flashback and
Kovacs was in his original sleeve and we
had another actor that der was even
worse and I made me rise okay so Joel
Kinnaman is bringing something to this
cuz this guy is so much worse and it
moved away from the cool futuristic
setting and it was set in like these
cheap-looking Forgetting caves and woods
and it was just so stupid episode 6
basically introduced a character it it
pulled a villain completely out of its
bush and I'm just gonna start spoiling
this thing at this point because I think
it's stupid
and I don't care so after focusing and
being about this mystery or getting us a
climate into this world and the people
who live in it and get damaged by it out
of nowhere at the end of episode 5 into
episode 6 if I've got my timing right
I'm not going back to check this woman
shows up and is introduced in the
laziest writing fashion she looks at
Kovac she goes hi big brother
yes we knew he had a younger sister we
saw her previously as a child and tiny
little moments of flashbacks in short
brief things that actually kind of
worked they didn't add a ton but they
also weren't dwelled on and they weren't
horrendously written like episode 7 and
the prolonged flashback is but she comes
out of nowhere we had no indication that
she was even still alive much less
anything else
so she shows up out of nowhere she is
she is and she's now the villain and it
pulls the whole friggin stupid thing
that like Spectre decided to do with its
Blofeld we're like everything has been
orchestrated by me to get to you now
difference being she's not actually
trying to hurt
Kovach she's she's she wants it back
because she's so in love with him but
like it's so stupid and it is a complete
harsh gear shift of what the show is
even about and she is such generic lousy
uninteresting all-powerful villain and
she has a boring religious monologue
spouting henchmen who also just so it's
all just so generic the second half of
this like the first half wasn't amazing
by any means but it was engaging I was
curious
but the second half dear god it's so bad
and like by the end of the last episode
a spoiler alert he kills his sister and
like that happened am i oh good it's
winding down I checked the time real
quick 20 minutes left Lord if these
episodes felt in so long so long by the
time it was done now before I get any
more ranty about this let me point out
some of the stuff that does actually
work because there are a few things
namely there's a handful of supporting
characters who are actually quite good
now please note any supporting
characters who I don't Men
we're probably either mad - not good at
all because you've got crap like the
generic police corrupt police chief
doofus and the partner who's overly
protective of Ortega for no particular
reason and the Weasly tech guy is like
yeah I've seen all these but one who's
awesome po-po is awesome I love PO in
concept and I love the performance so
when Kovac needs a base of operations he
goes to something that's actually it's
not I was gonna say defunct but it's up
and running and it's functional but like
they're not really a thing anymore it's
just still there because it's got an
active license and it hasn't fallen
apart so what's called an AI Hotel so
there's no no humans who work there it
has come the entire building is
controlled by an AI which controls you
know defenses in the lobby and the room
service and everything else and this AI
has decided to model itself after a
growl and Pope calls itself Po and he is
wonderful he is fun and engaging he's
the one of the only characters who seems
to be taking any enjoyment out of
anything he's witty he's empathetic he's
just awesome I mean I I like in general
I like either robots or a eyes with a
lot of personality and he has that I
love him he's terrific and there's a few
other performances as well there's a
performance of a character named Ava
which is a a female character in a male
sleeve and not by her choice it was the
only sleep available and that
performance is kind of interesting I'm
not sure how good it is but I found it
interesting I also kind of liked that as
soon as it's established that this is
Ava that you know even her husband kind
of doesn't make a deal out of it that's
kind of nice that it didn't become like
a massive thing
so there's that Matt Frewer is in it for
a couple of episodes kind of channeling
Max Headroom a little bit again which
was kind of fun to see um James Purefoy
perfor I don't know how to pronounce his
last name um he plays the you know the
big rich guy who hired Kovach and he's
good for that he he has a slightly off
vibe which is good for this kind of this
guy's rich and probably shady kind of
thing he's got honestly the general vibe
I gotta of him he reminded me a little
bit of of Christopher Lambert from the
Highlander he kind of just has that boy
something's a little off about you I'm a
little intrigued so there's things like
that there's characters like that that
are nice or fun but they're the minority
of the cast the show looks good like I
said but it's aping so much from a much
better known film and also even in the
first half which as I said was better I
still wasn't especially engaged because
the fact that it was a big Blade Runner
so much not only individual but also in
tone even though the specifics of the
way this world works aren't exactly
lifted from Blade Runner it is going for
that same sort of new are everything's
dark everybody sucks
tone and for me at least if you are
going to so clearly ape and recycle an
established world that I know you know
even if you're not literally sitting in
there but it's very clearly that's what
your inspiration is for me I really
would prefer that you not tell me a
story that is also totally similar I
want you to do something different if
you're gonna present me with something
visually so familiar so like for example
if I read or watch a like an epic
fantasy story that's set in a very
tolkien-esque world I don't I want a
different feel I actually if it's gonna
be set in a world like that I don't
really want it to be a big fantasy I
wanted to be something else like a great
example of that is something like rat
Queens which basically is set in a
Dungeons and Dragons world
is way more humorous in its approach
then as opposed to grand quest adventure
and like that shift in tone from what
I'm used to seeing when I see things in
that kind of world that makes it fun
whereas this is aping blade runner's
aesthetic as well as its tone and it
makes me go yeah now I've seen a movie
that did all this stuff way better so I
don't know really what uh-oh there is
one other thing that I want to bring up
because apparently is based off a book
that I haven't read but here's what I
found interesting it just as a quick
comparison because I want I wanted to
know who to blame and I'm gonna blame
the show I'm not gonna blame the book
and again I haven't read the book and I
don't know if the book is good but I am
gonna go I don't let me say the book is
better than the show and the reason I
feel comfortable in saying that is most
of the worst things in the show were
made up for the show they weren't in the
book like the sister she's not in the
book Wow like there is a characters kind
of like that but they don't have it be
his sister and the flashbacks are like
his entire backstory is different and he
wasn't a resistance fighter he was just
an elite cop basically and like all the
stupidest stuff is in the show and not
in the book
so I'm gonna make the declarative
statement books better I haven't read
the book I still feel very comfortable
in saying that I understand that to a
certain degree it is dealing with
character I mean it's it's one of the
themes and again it doesn't know how to
be subtle with its theming but this
whole thing of how living for too long
and having too much power basically can
drive people mad and corrupt and bring
out the absolute worst in them and a lot
of this is exemplified in the laziest
way that you would expect which is by
really twisted violent sexual tastes in
the upper ruling class and I understand
that being there as far as the theming
goes but it
shown a lot and it just keeps coming up
well after it's been established and at
a point it's not it doesn't tell us
anything anymore and it becomes a
gratuitous fairly quickly and it keeps
going and nearly every major female
character gets naked at some point in
this thing and yet there is some male
nudity but it the the level of violence
of sexual violence is not only pervasive
but also after a while it's numbing coz
like there's this whole thing in the
climax where they're taking down
basically this floating pleasure palace
of the rich and they're trying to weird
and gross us out you know the gross out
the audience but like this is all stuff
they've already shown us like okay this
is slightly worse but like I could have
guessed based off what you already
showed us that this is also here and it
like it loses any impact
it doesn't escalate it's just dumped on
us so early on the idea that because
people can be received that sex workers
if they're paid well enough can afford
to have their bodies literally destroyed
and then just receive in another body
and the show doesn't really seem to have
a point for how often it brings this up
because it comes up a lot and way more
than needs to happen to make its point
okay we're gonna wrap up there altered
carbon did not like it
very much at all now I understand like
their reefs leaving cohosh for the next
season Anthony Mackie I love Anthony
Mackie still not gonna watch it this was
awful I was swearing at it by the end so
that's all to carbon season 1 I really
hope that the person who commissioned me
for it isn't like a
each fan of it in which case I'm very
sorry I I really I really hate when I
feel like I'm letting someone down
because they had me review something
they liked but I don't know they
actually didn't tell me what they
thought I was gonna think of it so who
knows I hope you're not too disappointed
in any case
have you seen Ultra carbon season 1 what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
cuz there's buttons and links there's
the patreon which I mentioned before
I'll plug it again subscribe hit the
like button folks have been doing that
more lately and it does actually seem to
be helping so much appreciate it there
all that stuff to do or don't I'm not
gonna make you because at the end of the
day you're the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]